Sed honestos, ¿quién demonios no se ha tomado,
al menos una vez en su vida, una taza de café?
Seguro que todos, absolutamente todos, los
que nos estáis viendo habréis consumido
este producto en alguna ocasión. Y luego,
claro, están las personas que como me pasa
a mi, nos pasamos el día enganchados a esta
placentera y revitalizante bebida.
¿Os imagináis empezar el día sin una buena
taza rebosante por la mañana? Yo no.
El café se ha convertido en uno de esos productos
globales que nos vamos a poder encontrar en
prácticamente cualquier rincón del mundo.
Ahora bien, ¿nunca os habéis preguntado
qué hay más allá de vuestra humeante taza
de café?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a contar cuáles son los principales
detalles, características y retos de esta
apasionante industria. Un mercado del que
no se habla mucho, pero que, sin embargo,
es uno de los más grandes del mundo por volumen
de transacciones económicas. Cada vez se
consume más y más café.
Ya lo veis, no hablamos, ni mucho menos, de
una industria precisamente pequeña. Durante
el 2020 el negocio del café movió más de
450 mil millones de dólares.
¿Estás preparado para adentrarte con nosotros
en este apasionante mundo que nos acompaña
cada mañana? Además, en esta ocasión vamos
a poder escuchar también la experiencia de
EthicHub, una empresa que se dedica a la financiación
colaborativa de productores de café. Fueron
ellos quienes nos dieron la idea de preparar
este vídeo.
Arranquemos.
La industria cafetera es quizás una de las
más desconocidas de todas las grandes industrias
del mundo.
Por ejemplo, Latinoamérica produce el 70%
de de la producción mundial de grano de café,
al tiempo que los 6 mayores productores del
mundo son:
Brasil, Vietnam, Colombia, Indonesia, Honduras
y Etiopía.
Luego entre los 10 mayores productores encontramos
también a Perú, Guatemala y México.
Hasta aquí ninguna sorpresa, ¿verdad? Todos
ellos son países de renta baja con importantes
bolsas de pobreza, principalmente en el campo.
Sin embargo, junto a Brasil, Colombia y Vietnam,
en el top seis de los mayores exportadores
nos encontramos a Suiza, Alemania e Italia.
¿No hay algo que os llama la atención? Exacto,
en el mercado del café, los mayores productores
no son siempre quienes más dinero ingresan
con las exportaciones cafeteras.
Y eso que a pesar de que el café necesita
de unas condiciones climáticas muy específicas,
un determinado tipo de suelo, de temperatura,
de precipitaciones o altitud sobre el nivel
del mar. Es decir, que se cultiva café dónde
se puede cultivar café, lo que debería darle
a los productores un cierto poder mercado.
Pero claro, para entendernos, podríamos decir
que la bolsa de café que podemos comprar
en un supermercado sería algo así como el
equivalente a una camiseta de algodón en
una tienda de ropa, mientras que el café
que se recoge en Colombia sería como el algodón
recién salido de la flor.
Y claro, entre ambos productos existe un intenso
proceso de transformación y aportación de
valor. Y también, por supuesto, entre ambos
es dónde aparece el marketing. Luego veremos
porqué esto es importante, pero antes, para
empezar echemos un vistazo al caso de Suiza.
(Suiza es el segundo país del mundo que más
ingresa gracias a las exportaciones de café,
hablamos de casi 3.000 millones de dólares.
A pesar de que en el país alpino no hay plantaciones
de café sus exportaciones cafeteras superan
incluso a las de Colombia
Lo que resulta mucho decir, especialmente
si tenemos en cuenta que en el país latinoamericano
trabajan en el sector más de 700 mil personas
y el país produce cada año más de 14 millones
de sacos de 60 kg, un tipo de medida, estos
sacos, que vienen a ser al café lo que el
barril es al petróleo.
Pues bien, la cuestión es que Suiza importa
café sin tostar, esto es, al grano tal y
como sale del campo. Granos que luego son
tostados, empaquetados y vendidos de mil y
un formas diferentes,
Y es en esta diferencia, en la transformación
de un producto primitivo en un producto final,
donde se crea valor y el café multiplica
su precio. Y esa es exactamente la razón
por la que el país helvético genera tanto
negocio exportando café sin tener plantaciones
de este grano.
Empresas como la suiza Nestlé, que es el
tercer mayor importador privado de café,
transforman el primitivo grano salido por
ejemplo de Brasil en productos tan habituales
en la vida diaria de los países desarrollados
como son cápsulas de Nespresso.)
Y es justo aquí, donde se encuentra la clave
que convierte al café en un negocio muy lucrativo.
Y lo que explica que los agricultores del
café en muchos casos no vean ni una centésima
parte del precio al que finalmente se vende
su producción al consumidor.
Pero antes de que alguno empiece a culpar
a los [tono socarrón] “malvados capitalistas
que exprimen a los agricultores” lo cierto
es que todo tiene una explicación. Y tras
la explicación están también las posibles
soluciones
¿Hasta qué punto los países productores
se aprovechan del enorme negocio mundial del
café? ¿Cómo es posible que Suiza tenga
un sector cafetero tan grande como el de la
mismísima Colombia por volumen de negocio?
Pues bien, veámoslo. Pero antes, antes vamos
a conocer a nuestros amigos de EthicHub que
han querido apoyar a VisualPolitik y que tienen
un proyecto que a nosotros nos ha llamado
mucho pero que mucho la atención.
Apunte, cuando terminéis de ver este vídeo
lo entenderéis todo mucho mejor.
Y ahora con vuestro permiso lanzó la primera
pregunta, ¿qué es exactamente EthicHub?
Qué interesante Gabriela, personalmente este
tipo de proyectos me suenan fenomenal. Esa
idea de compaginar el ánimo de lucro con
impulsar el desarrollo me encanta. Pero, ¿por
qué creéis que vuestro modelo es mejor para
la industria del café?
Bien, en este mismo vídeo vamos a indagar
en todas estas cuestiones, pero Gabriela hay
una pregunta que es obligada: ¿Qué ventajas
tiene apostar por EthicHub a la hora
de invertir?
Muchas gracias XXX por nuestro apoyo a la
hora de montar este vídeo. Dejamos el enlace
a vuestra web en la descripción para quien
esté interesado en conocer mejor vuestro
proyecto.
Y ahora, para todos vosotros, repito la pregunta,
¿Cómo es posible que Suiza tenga un sector
cafetero tan grande como el de la mismísima
Colombia por volumen de negocio?
(LA HUELLA DEL CAFÉ)
Amigos, la industria del café ha cambiado
mucho en las últimas décadas: desde las
cápsulas hasta las máquinas de vending o
los starbucks. La industria del café, amigos,
no para de transformarse y cada vez la experiencia
cuenta más.
Lo que no ha cambiado tanto es la situación
de los principales países productores de
café, al menos no por esta materia prima.
(Las regiones cafeteras siguen siendo en muchos
casos sinónimo de subdesarrollo. En concreto,
hablamos de unos 25 millones de pequeños
productores de café, el 80% de los cuales
viven por debajo del umbral de la pobreza.
Una industria millonaria asentada sobre la
absoluta miseria.
Por ejemplo, en Colombia, un país que exhala
café por sus cuatro costados, las exportaciones
cafeteras apenas suponen el 0,7% de su economía.
Y en Brasil, el mayor productor mundial, apenas
el 0,3%)
Dicho de otra forma, el café es más lucrativo
para la economía suiza que para la mismísima
Colombia, ¡De locos!
Pero, entonces, la pregunta es: ¿Qué demonios
pasa aquí? ¿Qué problemas tienen los países
productores? ¿Por qué países como Colombia,
Honduras o Brasil son incapaces de explotar
esta enorme fuente de riqueza?
Pues, principalmente podemos destacar 3 grandes
obstáculos:
En primer lugar está el tamaño de los productores.
Entre el 70 y el 80 por ciento de todo el
café que se produce en el mundo lo producen
pequeños agricultores a través de minifundios,
de pequeñas plantaciones.
Y esto, que a priori a muchos de vosotros
os puede parecer un dato poco relevante, y
a otros, incluso, un escenario que evoca al
activismo y romanticismo social - esos pequeños
agricultores saliendo adelante con sus propias
manos trabajando el campo mañana, tarde y
noche- resulta clave para explicar porqué
el café es más lucrativo en Suiza que en
Colombia.
(La inmensa mayoría de esos 25 millones de
pequeños productores de café se encuentran
en zonas rurales y empobrecidas de países
que ya de por sí son bastante pobres.
Es decir, hablamos de productores sin medios
económicos suficientes como para invertir
en bienes de capital, como por ejemplo, tractores
con los que mejorar la productividad de sus
plantaciones o desarrollar modelos de negocio
más complejos.
Es la pescadilla que se muerde la cola. No
tener recursos les impide desarrollarse, y
al no desarrollarse no tienen los recursos
que necesitan para prosperar y mejorar su
nivel de vida.)
Y justo aquí encontramos el segundo gran
problema al que se enfrentan los pequeños
agricultores del café.
Si uno de estos agricultores o varios de ellos
quisieran montar su propia planta de tostado
y procesamiento de café, necesitarían enormes
cantidades de dinero. Es decir, tendrían
que pedir un préstamo o buscar un inversor.
¡Problema!Tal y cómo vimos en el vídeo
sobre cómo se malogró el Perú,
en estos países los mercados financieros
están muy poco desarrollados, de tal forma
que conseguir un préstamo para un agricultor
es casi una tarea imposible y de hacerlo se
enfrentaría a tipos de interés que pueden
superar incluso el 40% anual.
Así que, resumiendo, no tienen dinero para
crecer, al no crecer no pueden prosperar,
y al no prosperar no pueden acceder a un préstamo
Para colmo, y este es el tercer gran problema,
al no desarrollar actividades más complejas
los pequeños agricultores quedan totalmente
expuestos a las variaciones de precio que
se producen en el mercado internacional.
Por ejemplo, cuando hay una buena cosecha,
si esta se da a nivel general, o cuando las
plantaciones aumentan puede ocurrir que los
agricultores vean hundirse los precios incluso
muy por debajo de su coste de producción.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en este gráfico para
ver lo volátil que resulta el precio del
café.
Y la pregunta es,: ¿Cómo demonios se puede
escapar de esta especie de círculo vicioso?
Pues, aquí podemos encontrar al menos dos
posibilidades:
Una podría ser fomentar la agrupación de
los agricultores de café en cooperativas,
de modo que entre ellos puedan formar un ente
más grande que fuera capaz de acceder más
fácilmente a tecnología, mejores acuerdos
comerciales o financiación. Incluso podrían,
llegado el caso, apoyarse entre sí.
Pero claro, aún así hablamos de castillos
en el aire. Para estos pequeños agricultores
que en muchos casos no saben leer ni escribir
desarrollar organizaciones más complejas
no resulta tan sencillo y además se necesita
de la participación de muchos productores,
productores que no siempre pueden cambiar
su actividad tradicional porque viven al día.
Si le venden a un comprador le tienen que
seguir vendiendo para poder comer. Un embrollo.
Para colmo tampoco se resuelve la gran cuestión:
incluso para formar entes empresariales o
cooperativas hace falta dinero. En esta misma
línea, en algunos países como es el caso
de Colombia existen instituciones que han
tratado de hacer frente a este problema. Fijaos.
(En Colombia existe la Federación Nacional
de Cafeteros, un ente nacido en 1927 que a
través del llamado Fondo Nacional del Café
asegura la compra de toda la producción de
sus miembros a precios de mercado. Esta entidad
que opera por mandato del gobierno colombiano
funciona a través de una red compuesta por
36 cooperativas y más de 500 puntos de compra
repartidos a lo largo y ancho de todo el país.
Gracias a su mayor poder de negociación en
el mercado, la Federación logra precios sustancialmente
mayores a los que lograría un pequeño campesino.
Hablamos de importes que pueden llegar a ser
un 40 o incluso un 50% más altos. Cada año
estas cooperativas gestionan más del 30%
de toda la producción colombiana.)
El problema es que, habiendo sido muy útil,
al final en muchos casos se ha manifestado
cómo un instrumento insuficiente. ¿Por qué?
Pues porque le han garantizado a los pequeños
agricultores la compra de su producción pero
no han ido mucho más. Al final este tipo
de entidades tan grandes, burocráticas y
poco expuestas al mercado tienen limitaciones.
Y la mejor prueba es que tras 75 años de
vida esta Federación dio el salto y puso
en marcha la cadena de cafeterías Juan Valdez,
para incrementar el valor generado por los
productores colombianos. Ya tienen más de
120 establecimientos repartidos por todo el
mundo. Es el auténtico rival colombiano de
Starbucks.
Seguro que ahora entendéis porque esta marca
utiliza el: El Café de todo Un País
En cualquier caso, amigos, es aquí dónde
surge la segunda posibilidad: que sería la
de poder acceder a microcréditos colaborativos,
un instrumento que poco a poco ha ido cobrando
más y más peso.
Y, ¿en qué consisten estos microcréditos?
Pues en préstamos pequeños que se entregan
sin necesidad de tener un aval y con tipos
de interés de mercado pero mucho más ajustados.
Con ellos un pequeño agricultor puede comprar
más tierras, comprar un tractor, comprar
máquinas, etc, etc.
De esta forma podrían escapar del círculo
vicioso: Acceden a recursos con los que poder
crecer, al crecer mejoran su nivel de vida
y reintegran los préstamos. Le hemos dado
la vuelta al problema.
Y por este motivo, los microcréditos colaborativos
están creciendo tanto en los países subdesarrollados.
Amigos, impulsar este tipo de fórmulas podría
contribuir a reducir mucho la pobreza, especialmente
en América Latina. Y es que no solo hablamos
de los más de 25 millones de pequeños productores
sino de millones y millones de personas que
podrían mejorar sus vidas por la mejora de
la economía local en las zonas rurales de
países cómo México, Brasil, Colombia, Honduras
o Guatemala.
Para mejorar la vida de los agricultores del
café y convertir a esta industria en un motor
de riqueza no hace falta menos mercado, sino
todo lo contrario.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Te habías parado a pensar en lo que hay
detrás del café que te tomas cada mañana?
¿Cuál crees que sería la mejor fórmula
para mejorar la vida de las millones y millones
de personas que se dedican a plantar café?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a Visualpolitik si aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima